so look I just signed my WWE contract it
is a big deal Logan Paul is officially
heading to the ring I've been I think
it's an awesome idea the social media
star signed a multi-event contract with
WWE and celebrated the promotion with
WWE exec's Triple H and Stephanie
McMahon I
I don't have a WWE fan base and I think
that's why they like me here is I'm able
to I I believe part of my value comes in
Bridging the Gap between like mainstream
and this WWE world and I can kind of do
this a little bit and the YouTuber first
appeared at WrestleMania 37 in 2021 as a
guest of Superstar Sami Zayn and as
Logan told ET last year he wasn't
entirely sure what to expect so Sami
Zayn uh the WWE Superstar invited me out
to be a special guest for his red carpet
premiere of his documentary I don't know
I don't know what we're doing
um I think he's just gonna show me show
me his documentary I don't know we'll
see what happens
Logan Logan you're my guest of honor
it's the enemy
[Applause]
in April he wowed the wrestling world
when he returned for Wrestlemania 38
this time tag teaming with the Miz
against the mysterios ready to go
toe-to-toe Logan Paul not having it
it was a trap that's just one get ready
for number two there it is
unbelievable I gotta win I gotta win
something this is great but things soon
turned sour between the partners when
The Miz betrayed Logan after a fight
hitting him with a skull crushing finale
I'm still processing why Miz betrayed me
to be honest with you if I had to guess
he's probably jealous now that he's
officially a WWE member Logan's got a
message for his former teammate
thank you
yeah you read that right assuming you
can read I'm coming for you Liz yeah
Logan didn't waste the opportunity to
let the Miz and his future opponents
know he's definitely not here to mess
around I
am so dangerous I feel so confident
um I don't know if I've ever felt more
confident about anything in my life not
only has Logan participated in WWE he's
also dabbled in boxing and E.T spoke
with him last year as he geared up for
the big match that brought Floyd
Mayweather out of retirement I did The
Impossible already
so I'm just going to do it again Sunday
already is I'll ever be yeah like uh you
know if you stay ready you don't got to
get ready something about the energy for
a for a wrestling event in a boxing
match is so different so different
wrestling's more fun right so we likely
won't see Logan return to the boxing
ring for a while but for now we'll watch
him take on the wrestling world it is
electric when there's someone you love
in that ring and and doing those moves
like by the way I didn't I didn't
practice like any of those moves it's
because you know you're doing it on a
that surface is hard it is not bouncy it
is not a trampoline there is no give it
is plywood it's wood and so everyone you
know wrestling's fake shut up I want to
be humble and I and I will but like I'm
good at this so good I'm actually good
at it
foreign
[Music]